Como cada mañana más Romero sale nos
trae las noticias en temas de salud Omar
Buenos días para usted Buenos días
Ángela no tan buenas sin embargo las
noticias en Guinea ecuatorial por
primera vez mar hay un brote de la
enfermedad por el virus de marburgo sí
es una enfermedad hemorrágica empezamos
diciendo eso no tan extendida pero
bastante grave de la cual se han
detectado actualmente 16 presuntos casos
en intimidad ecuatorial y nueve muertes
es la primera vez como decías que se
detecta en este país aunque han habido
brotes en otros países y ayer se
anunciaron además dos casos presuntos
más en Camerún en una zona fronteriza
con Guinea ecuatorial las autoridades
aseguran que ya están pues haciendo la
actividad de buscar los contactos de
estas dos personas a quienes se cree que
podrían tener la enfermedad y en Guinea
ecuatorial hay 21 personas totalmente
aisladas y más de 4.000 también en
cuarentena en su casa para evitar que se
siga extendiendo esta enfermedad Vamos a
repasar un poco datos de este de esta
enfermedad no es una enfermedad que se
transmite por estrecho de fluidos
corporales por ejemplo por heridas
sangre también las mucosas o a través de
superficies como la ropa la ropa de cama
de personas que estén infectadas salta
de murciélagos a humanos y aquí tenemos
una lista de sus principales síntomas
fiebres altas dolores de cabeza dolores
musculares también diarrea y náuseas y
sobre todo cuando entra a etapas ya más
severas estamos hablando de hemorragias
que pueden llegar a ser graves la
principal causa de muerte por ejemplo es
a través de la hemorragia no Y la
afectación al sistema nervioso Como por
ejemplo eso con confusión o
irritabilidad presenta síntomas como
vemos bastante parecidos con el ébola
con la fiebre del Asa que son otras
fiebres hemorrágicas presentes en la
región nada fácil de tratar cuál puede
ser el alcance de este brote actual al
mar pues es una enfermedad cuya
mortalidad ha oscilado entre el 24% y el
88% dependiendo de Cuál ha sido no la
respuesta de las autoridades y la
respuesta de la salud pública es
definitivamente una enfermedad grave
para las personas que la contagian y
Vamos a repasar algunos de los brotes
que se han dado en el pasado para
entender que se alcance el primero fue
en Alemania y en la Serbia actual en
1967 a raíz de unos animales importados
de uganda por eso lleva este nombre
enfermedad de marburgo de la enfermedad
de la enfermedad perdón de la ciudad
alemana marburgo que fue donde primero
se detectó los más graves en términos de
cifras numéricamente fueron en República
democrática del Congo y en Angola con
centenares de muertes y vemos una
mortalidad más alta de un 80 por ciento
luego han habido algunos brotes
puntuales recurrentemente en Kenia o en
uganda los dos últimos fueron en Guinea
y gana
2021-2022 con pocos casos se controló
por suerte muy rápidamente pero
actualmente vemos devolviendo a estas
cifras no que el brote actual ya tiene
18 presuntos casos es definitivamente
uno de los más virulentos en la última
década no significa que vaya a ser una
emergencia internacional pero significa
que se tiene que responder de forma
rápida y veloz claro y que hay que
prestarle atención vamos a pasar a otro
tema Turquía a raíz del terremoto Sí lo
hacemos porque la agencia pudo entrar a
un hospital de campaña del ejército
indio en la ciudad turca de alejandreta
y hablaron con uno de los con una de las
doctoras escuchémoslo
Durante los primeros tres días la
mayoría de pacientes eran víctimas del
terremoto ahora vemos que gradualmente
han bajado un poco
vienen menos pacientes con heridas del
terremoto ahora llegan más personas con
trastorno de estrés postraumático con
todo el impacto de estos días
por todo lo que han visto hay varios
pacientes con ataques de pánico
hablaban también de más pacientes con
enfermedades infecciosas con
enfermedades crónicas sin acceso a sus
tratamientos habituales y con otras
afectaciones de Salud Mental es un
testimonio más de lo que veníamos
diciendo en otros espacios de salud aquí
que además de las primeras de los primer
impacto de un terremoto no siempre va a
haber estas consecuencias sobre la salud
que se van a ir viendo en los días
semanas meses incluso años a venir no es
que ya lo decíamos los rescates que se
den de ahora en adelante son
prácticamente Milagros y ahora pasan a
las tareas para dar prioridad a las
personas que sobrevivieron y terminamos
con una fecha hoy es el Día Mundial
contra el cáncer infantil Sí recordemos
bueno Un día como hoy es la principal
causa de muerte en niños y adolescentes
en todo el mundo afecta Aproximadamente
a 400.000 personas entre los 0 y los 19
años niños y jóvenes en todo el mundo y
en los países de más recursos en más del
80% logran curarse Pero es en los países
de ingresos bajos o medios que no logran
pasar de menos del 30% la cantidad de
pacientes que logran a curarse es un
dato definitivamente doloroso que
muestra que muchos de estos casos de
cáncer se pueden curar gracias a
tratamientos que existen pero que
dependen principalmente de que las
personas tengan acceso precisamente a
este tipo de tratamientos el cáncer
infantil es difícil de detectar con
controles rutinarios por eso es
importante estar pendiente por ejemplo
cosas como dolores de cabeza duros
graves y continuados una pérdida de peso
que no tenga un motivo aparente Por lo
cual se pueda explicar también dolores
articulares o musculares no y que además
como la mayoría de Estos tipos de cáncer
no son dados por factores ambientales no
se conoce tanto Cuál es su origen se
cree que alrededor del 10% responde a
motivos genéticos pero el resto sigue
siendo una incógnita por eso también en
un día como hoy pedimos más
investigación porque muchas veces
conocer el origen de esta enfermedad es
un camino también para conocer sus curas
y honramos los videos de los niños que
están en esta lucha gracias a usted mal
gracias Ángela